[Música]
vamos a las noticias de la economía con
Daniela Blandón Daniela Buenos días para
usted Hola Buenos días Ángela Bueno
vamos a hablar del que es el tema del
día esto no es ninguna sorpresa pero
usted nos va a dar un enfoque de
diferente Qué papel tiene el mercado de
valores en esta elección desde medio
término en Estados Unidos pues Ángela de
los inversionistas están más pendientes
de esta elección de lo que nosotros nos
imaginamos Pues de cómo estén las cargas
en el congreso depende la agenda del
presidente de acuerdo con un análisis de
rbc capital Markets cuando un demócrata
está en la casa blanca como está
ocurriendo en este momento el mejor
desempeño del mercado se da cuando los
republicanos hacen contrapeso en una de
las dos cámaras o en ambas que no es lo
que está pasando hoy esta firma recoge
datos desde 1932 para analizar por
ejemplo el comportamiento del índice de
standard de la bolsa de Nueva York
primero digamos que es este índice es
una canasta que aglutina 500 de las
empresas más grandes por valor de
Mercado de un total de que cotizan en
Wall Street Pues cuando hay un
presidente demócrata y el congreso está
dividido la estadística reza que este
índice sube un promedio del 14% anual
pero si está controlado por republicanos
ese rendimiento del standard Baja un
punto y si los demócratas tienen la
mayoría legislativa esa valorización es
del 10%. quiere decir que al mercado le
gusta más que las cámaras estén
divididas y que es estándar en pulsa
caído un 20% este año aunque esto último
pues es inusual escuchemos el análisis
que hacen desde Wall Street si tenemos
elecciones pero también tendremos el
dato del ipc en menos de 48 horas y eso
podría superar cualquier Euforia
electoral Por así decirlo
la gente cree que un gobierno dividido
es mejor verdad y las estadísticas nos
dicen que a un gobierno dividido le va
mejor
Aquí está la gran cosa tienes que ver
una inflación máxima que aún no
conocemos tienes que ver una pausa en la
Fed que no vemos todavía y probablemente
tengas que ver la paz en Ucrania Esas
son las tres cosas que estamos buscando
para que haya resultados positivos en el
mercado
hablemos ahora de cuáles son esos
sectores económicos que están más
dependientes de la elección pues son
todos por supuesto pero podríamos decir
que el sector salud estaría más feliz de
tener un congreso republicano porque se
frenarían las iniciativas demócratas
para impulsar políticas más estrictas
sobre los precios de los medicamentos
recetados y eso podría respaldar las
acciones de farmacéuticas y
biotecnológicas también una victoria
republicana podría aumentar las
expectativas de un mayor gasto en
defensa y una legislación más favorable
para la industria de los combustibles
fósiles Ahora nos vamos para una
eventual Victoria demócrata esto podría
ayudar a las acciones de las empresas de
energía limpia y del Cannabis dadas las
expectativas de que el partido
probablemente favorecería una
legislación más amigable para estas
industrias los analistas también dicen
que podría seguir impulsando el dólar
porque se esperaría un gasto fiscal más
alto del lado demócrata y esto podría
seguir presionando la reserva Federal
para subir más las tasas de interés más
las tasas más altas dólar más alto en
estos comicios además Daniela estaban en
juego otras propuestas electorales usted
nos va a explicar y hablemos
específicamente de economía Miren el
estado más poblado del país que es
California se votaron propuestas sobre
apuestas deportivas en persona y en
casinos dirigidos por tribus indígenas
las campañas que tuvieron inversiones
millonarias pero que fracasaron la
primera propuesta habría permitido las
apuestas deportivas en persona en
casinos de tribus indígenas pero
solamente tuvo un apoyo del 30% según
resultados preliminares la otra
propuesta rechazada fue impulsada por
las principales casas de apuestas
deportivas para que California
legalizara el juego a través de
dispositivos móviles o de tabletas y
esto solamente tuvo el 16% de
favorabilidad Hay que decir que
California es uno de los estados más
restrictivos para los juegos de suerte y
Azar y en otros temas de que hay que
discutir de economía una noticia que
estábamos esperando la matriz de
Facebook que reconoció Que hará recortes
de personal ya fueron anunciados ya
fueron anunciados confirmados por Mark
Zuckerberg el ceo de metaplatforms que
es la matriz de Facebook pero también de
Instagram y de WhatsApp dijo hoy que va
a despedir al 13% de su fuerza laboral
Estos son más de 11.000 empleados y es
el primer despido masivo en sus 18 años
de historia porque ocurre porque la
empresa está contra los costos altísimos
y también un mercado publicitario débil
esta decisión le sigue a los miles de
recortes de empleos en otras gigantes
tecnológicas como Twitter y Microsoft el
fundador decidió entonces de Facebook
Mark Zuckerberg reconoció en una nota a
sus empleados que se equivocó cuando
hizo un mal cálculo de los ingresos
esperados que van a ser mucho menores y
por eso tienen que hacer todos estos
recortes súper lamentable Pero bueno
está ocurriendo en todo el sector y que
lo veníamos hablando esta semana que no
se lo esperaban las tecnológicas tener
como este bajones después de la pandemia
así Ahora hay otra noticia que ustedes
nos trajo hace no muchas semanas sobre
un incentivo cambiario para turistas que
al parecer según se ha visto no está
funcionando en Argentina pues la semana
pasada Ángel al Banco Central formalizó
el anuncio del Ministerio de economía de
que todos los gastos que hicieran en
Argentina con tarjetas de crédito débito
y tarjetas prepagas que estuvieran fuera
del país iban a ser convertidos ya no al
tipo de cambio oficial sino un tipo de
cambio financiero que es más ventajoso
esto iba a ser desde el pasado viernes
es decir a precios de Hoy les iban a
reconocer el doble del valor a los
turistas para que no tuvieran que vender
sus Divisas en el mercado informal sin
embargo en redes sociales abundan las
denuncias de quienes dicen haber pagado
con su tarjeta en los últimos días pero
detectaron que su consumo fue convertido
al tipo de cambio oficial un usuario
hizo la denuncia ante el Banco Central y
este le respondió que debería Buscar
respuestas a su queja en la entidad
bancaria y así abundan los casos sin que
se tenga hasta el momento una respuesta
oficial de las autoridades económicas
pues qué problema vamos ahora por favor
a la cifra del día Ángela 2040 millones
de dólares por este monto cayó el premio
de lotería más alto en la historia de
Estados Unidos este premio comenzó en 20
millones de dólares el 6 de agosto y
llevaba tres meses acumulándose el
billete de Powerball adquirido en una
tienda en el Sur de California cuyo
dueño recibió un Bono de un millón de
dólares por venderlo el récord anterior
lo habían ganado tres personas por un
valor de más de 1.500 millones de
dólares ahora le tengo un dato el
ganador puede elegir entre una anualidad
durante 29 años pero lo otro es que
reciban el dinero en efectivo que es lo
que hace la gran mayoría y después de
impuestos en este caso quedaría un poco
más de mil millones de dólares el último
dato las probabilidades de ganar este
premio mayor son de una en 292 millones
quién fuera el ganador para tomar esa
difícil decisión no Y la difícil
decisión es Qué hacer con ese dinero
se nos ocurren ideas gracias Daniel a
ustedes y nos vemos más tarde para la
actualización y señora de una horita